let's now see if we can use integration
by parts to take the antiderivative of e
to the X cosine of X DX and this one's
an interesting one you'll see why in a
few in a few minutes because here if I
take the derivative of either of these
it doesn't get appreciably more simple
or appreciably more complicated if I
were to take its antiderivative the
derivative of e to the X is e to the X
the antiderivative of e DX is e to the X
derivative of cosine of X is negative
sine of X antiderivative cosine of X is
sine of X it seems to be about
comparable and because of that we can
essentially let's just arbitrarily
assign one of these to be f of X and the
other one to be G prime of X there isn't
neither one of them simplifies
dramatically or gets more complicated
when I take the derivative or the
antiderivative so let's say that f of X
is equal to e to the X and let's set G
prime of X to be equal to cosine of X so
given that we can write over here
that f of X is equal to e to the X F
prime of X is equal to e to the X we can
write that G prime of X the derivative
of G is equal to cosine of X and then
the antiderivative G of X could just be
equal to could be equal to sine of X so
let's apply integration by parts this
whole thing will simplify to this will
be equal to f of X times G of X so this
is e to the x times sine of X times sine
of X sine of X minus the antiderivative
minus the antiderivative of F prime of X
well F prime of X is e to the X so it's
going to be e to the X e to the X times
G of x times sine of X times sine of X
so once again this doesn't doesn't look
like we've gotten obviously any more
simple this so far this this this
antiderivative situation is about as
hard as this one right over here but
let's let's keep going to see if
something interesting might happen you
might guess what might happen so let's
see how we can evaluate whoops I want to
do select that let's think about how we
can
you ate this thing here so let me copy
and paste it so copy and paste so let's
let's evaluate let's try to evaluate
this thing right over here and similarly
we can do it using integration by parts
so now let's set f of X once again
equaling e to the X so f of X is equal
to e to the X just like we did before f
prime of X is equal to e to the X we
could set G prime of X G prime of X is
equal to sine of X then G out G of X the
antiderivative sine of X is negative
cosine of X now let's apply integration
by parts again so this thing over here
remember this is what we're evaluating
this is this is what we're evaluating
now we're doing a second round of
integration by parts this is what we're
evaluating this is equal to f of X times
G of X f of X is e to the X it's e to
the X well we have a negative out here
so I'll write negative e to the X cosine
of X cosine of X and we got the negative
from the G of X I'll put that in pink as
well and then we have minus we have -
well we have minus the antiderivative of
F prime of X F prime of X is e to the X
is e to the X G of X G of X is negative
cosine of X so we could put the cosine
of X over here and then take the
negative out of the integral and so this
could become a positive subtracting
negative cosine subtracting this
integral which had a negative in it I
just took the negative out this became a
positive DX so you might say hey Sal it
looks like we're going in circles once
again we have another integral that was
no less complicated than this one it's
actually got us back to where we were in
the beginning but this is interesting
what if we assigned a variable to this
thing that we had in the beginning I
don't know let's call that a let's call
this thing a a is equal to this business
right over here
so now we can say that a we could say
that a is equal to this business which
is equal to e to the X
e to the X sine of X sine now I want to
do that same pink color sine of X and
I'm just using a to simplify the
notation a little bit e to the X sine of
X minus - this business which we just
figured out was negative e to the X
cosine of X so negative e to the X
cosine of X e to the X cosine of X
cosine of X and then this right over
here is our a again a was defined as the
antiderivative of e to the X cosine of X
so this right over here is our a again
so we're going to put a plus a just like
that and now let's see if we could solve
for a because a is what we cared about
so let's see what we can do a is equal
to a is equal to e to the X sine of X
sine of X and then distribute the
negative so it's going to be plus plus e
to the X e to the X cosine of X e to the
X cosine of X and then minus a minus a
do the a in blue - a I just distributed
this negative sign now if we want to
solve for a we could just add a to both
sides to get all the A's on the left
hand side and then we are left with two
a is equal to this business which I can
just copy and paste to a is equal to
that so let me copy and paste that to a
is equal to that or a which is what we
cared about in the beginning a is equal
to and now we definitely deserve a
drumroll a is equal to all of that
business
all of this business divided by 2
we're just solving for a is equal to all
of that business divided by 2 and
remember a is just what we wanted to
solve in the beginning a is equal to the
antiderivative the antiderivative of e
to
the X cosine of X DX and we're done
we were able to use integration by parts
twice to come around full circle to get
back to our original expression but then
we solved for that original expression
we had an equation in terms of that
original expression I just set a they be
equal to it so I didn't have to rewrite
it over and over again but we have our
original expression the antiderivative
of e to the X cosine of X is equal to
all of this business which is kind of a
neat expression right here it has the
kind of beauty to it as an e to the X
it's got sine of X plus cosine of X
you're taking somehow the average of
these two things it seems kind of just
like a neat thing